[Music]
east town is a
mixture of a number of different towns
in pennsylvania
around where i grew up and i wanted the
show to be about a certain place in the
world
a certain group of people these people
have been born here
they've been raised here and now they're
raising their children here
that sense of history and shared history
united history
that is very apparent in this particular
area of east town
is quite unique i would say um and
everyone knows a little bit about what
someone else is up to
and there's always the sort of resident
slightly annoying
character mayor would have to deal with
where hey out there
oh you're here i'm here we shot
primarily in what i would call an
excerpt of philadelphia
kind of like the southwestern area
outside chester county and delaware
county
and that really did inform so much it
was nice to kind of be
in a place that felt like america and it
wasn't so specifically a big
city we wanted to make sure that the
vibe of the show
and the feeling of east town was
specific in many different ways
we did it through location we would try
to pick a location that was
true to what it really was not just the
most picturesque
[Applause]
we would do it with costume our custom
designer would constantly be texting me
pictures from the wawa convenience store
just of people in the line the clothes
really all felt
lived in to me and of that place
for instance i mean i had i think a dave
matthews concert
t-shirt and like certain things that
maybe you won't even see on camera but
those little details for her
and for the actors are important
i wanted the show to have a grittiness
to it you have to have an honesty to it
to have a realness to it
these are people that get up every
morning and go to jobs they don't
necessarily love
but they do it out of a sense of duty
so i wanted to portray these communities
that exist that don't often get
any time on the screen in a way that was
heroic and noble and also really
sympathetic
we're asking parents if their child
might have seen something
please come forward every bit of
information helps at this point
what's beautiful about this story is
that it isn't just about the crime it
isn't just about the mystery and who's
done it
but it's about the families you have the
opportunity to sort of investigate all
the families and to see the effects that
the crime has had and get involved in
everybody's personal stories and see how
they're interwoven
so there's something kind of heightened
you know in the drama i suppose when it
is a small town
you're pushing everyone away
including you no i won't let you
the show is very much about compassion
and mercy
and looking out for your friends and
your neighbours and it's quite special
in that regard
very moving in that regard
you